let's multiply 40 times 70. so 40 times
we have the number 70.
so we could actually list that out the
number 70 40 different times and add it
up
but that's clearly a lot of computation
to do and there's got to be a faster way
so another way is to stick with
multiplication
but see if we can break these numbers up
this 40 and this 70 decompose them break
them up in some way to get numbers that
might be a little easier to multiply
with
for me multiplying by 10 is the easiest
number because i know the pattern to add
a zero
so
i'm going to break up 40
and say instead of forty four times ten
four times ten and forty are equivalent
they're the same thing so i can replace
the forty with a four times ten
and then for my seventy same thing i can
break this up and write seven times ten
seven times ten
so these two expressions forty times
seventy
and four times ten times seven times ten
are equal they're equivalent so they'll
have the same solution
but for me this one down here is simpler
to work out because of these times tens
so i'll solve this one knowing that i'll
get the same solution as i would have
for this top expression
so what we can do is we can reorder
these numbers in a different order to
again continue making this question
easier for us to solve
because in multiplication the order
doesn't matter if we have 5 times two
for example
that would be the same as two times five
they're both ten
five twos or two fives either way it's
ten
so we can change the order of the
numbers without changing the answer so
again we're going to change our
expression a little bit but what we're
not going to change is the solution
so i'm going to put my one digit numbers
first 4
times
and then i'll put the two digit numbers
the tens
times 10
and the other
times 10.
so we have all the same factors all the
same numbers in both of these
expressions they've just been reordered
and now i'll solve going across
4 times 7 is 28
and then we have 28 times 10 and times
another 10.
well the pattern for times 10 that we
know is when we multiply a whole number
like 28
times 10
we will add a 0 to the n 1 0 for that 0
and 10 because 28 times 10 is 28 tens 28
tens
or 280
and that multiplied 28 times 10 and then
if we multiply by this other 10 well we
have to add another zero
multiplying by 10 adds a zero so if we
multiply by two tens we add two zeros
so 28 times 10 times 10 is
which means
that this original expression we had
forty times seventy also has a solution
of twenty eight hundred or two thousand
eight hundred
let's try another example where we're
multiplying tens like this
let's try let's do something like let's
say maybe 90
times about
30.
90 times 30. so the first thing i'm
going to do is break up these numbers so
that i have tens
because again for me tens are easier to
multiply the numbers like 90 and 30.
so for 90 i'll write 9 times 10
and for 30
i'll write 3 times 10.
the expressions are equivalent we've
just written it in another way
and now i'll reorder these numbers to
put the one-digit numbers first so nine
times three
and then i'll put the tens times 10
times 10 because we need to have all the
same numbers even if we change the order
so we have the 9
the first 10
and the second 10.
and now finally we multiply
9 times 3 is 27
27 times 10
will be 27 tens or 27 with a zero on the
end
and 270 times 10 will be 270 tens or 270
with a zero on the end
so going back to the original question
90 times 30 is equal
to 27
hundred or 2
700.